(music)
Jeff Bezos:
My name is Jeff Bezos.
I studied electrical engineering and computer science,
Jeff Bezos:
graduated in 1986 from Princeton, and my current job,
I'm the founder and CEO of Amazon.com.
Jeff Bezos:
The Kindle is a wireless electronic reader.
We started working on it more than three years ago now,
Jeff Bezos:
more than, probably, almost five years ago now.
The idea is to take the key features of a physical book,
Jeff Bezos:
capture those and then go beyond that.
The number one feature of a physical book is that it
Jeff Bezos:
disappears while you're reading it.
You're not thinking about the ink and the glue and the
Jeff Bezos:
stitching and the paper.
You're entering the author's world and the physical object
Jeff Bezos:
just goes away. And that's what we wanted to
achieve with Kindle, to have a device so simple that
Jeff Bezos:
it too would disappear and let you enter the author's world.
Failure is an essential component of innovation and
Jeff Bezos:
invention. If you know it's going to work,
it's not an experiment.
Jeff Bezos:
And so if you want to invent, if you want to innovate,
failure is part and parcel with that.
Jeff Bezos:
There is no escape from that.
If I were to go back in time and give myself one piece of
Jeff Bezos:
advice as an undergraduate it would be: Take pride in your
decisions and hard work, but not in your gifts.
Jeff Bezos:
Celebrate your gifts.
Enjoy them.
Jeff Bezos:
But don't take pride in them.
Take pride in your decisions and hard work.
Jeff Bezos:
My best memory of Princeton is finishing problem sets in
partial differential equations.
Jeff Bezos:
And my worst memory of Princeton is starting my problem sets
in partial differential equations. (laughter)
Jeff Bezos:
For anybody who is starting -- for anybody,
it's their freshman week, and they are starting at Princeton --
Jeff Bezos:
I think the advice as to what to focus on is pretty simple,
which is to figure out -- which is not always easy -- but
Jeff Bezos:
try to figure out what you're genuinely interested in.
And then pursue those things. Alternative techniques might be
Jeff Bezos:
to try to figure out what you think is going to be most
lucrative. And I think those techniques tend
Jeff Bezos:
not to work. It's very, very difficult to chase after a wave.
What's better is to plant yourself in the middle of
Jeff Bezos:
something that you genuinely love and then wait for the wave
to come find you.
(music)
Jeff Bezos:
That just makes the video better, you guys.
You realize that, right, if there's a little bit of laugther that you can't quite cut out.
Jeff Bezos:
It's like the "Today Show," and the cameramen can't help but laugh.
Mike Wood:
And then the boom drops in the frame.
Jeff Bezos:
(laughter)